en este vídeo vamos a pensar en la
ganancia económica de un monopolio de
una empresa monopólica y para hacer eso
vamos a dibujar nuestros ejes de precio
y de cantidad
esto es cantidad y esto es precio en
pesos primero podemos pensar en la
demanda del producto de esta empresa
monopólica y la curva de demanda sería
similar a otras curvas de demanda que
hemos visto varias veces que a un precio
alto la gente no exige mucho y luego a
un precio más bajo o cuando el precio
baja la gente va a demandar una cantidad
cada vez mayor o el mercado exigirá una
cantidad mayor así que ésta podría ser
la curva de demanda ahora lo que es
interesante de cualquier empresa en
perfectamente competitiva y en el caso
extremo de un monopolio es el aspecto de
la curva de ingreso marginal dada esta
curva de demanda en una empresa
perfectamente competitiva la curva de
ingreso marginal es igual a la curva de
demanda y en esta situación en realidad
es una línea horizontal pero aquí dado
que en la empresa monopólica
el precio no sólo lo reduce en una
unidad adicional sería típico que
tuviera que reducir su precio en todas
las unidades y esto lo hemos estudiado
en otros vídeos tiene una curva de
ingreso marginal que descendería más
rápido que la curva de demanda se vería
algo así y si esto no te resulta
familiar te invito a que veas algunos de
los vídeos que explican a profundidad
por qué sucede esto entonces en un
monopolio o en realidad en cualquier
empresa en perfectamente competitiva su
curva de ingreso marginal disminuirá más
rápido que la curva de demanda así que
cuál sería una cantidad racional que
podría producir esta empresa bueno para
pensar en eso tenemos que pensar en su
curva de costo marginal de modo que su
curva de costo marginal la forma típica
en que pensamos a menudo en esto es que
al principio obtiene algunas economías
de escala
pero luego comienza a tener algunos
costos de coordinación y tal vez algunas
de economías de escala sus insumos
comienzan a ser más caros por lo que la
curva de costo marginal podría
y así la cantidad racional a producir
será siempre que el ingreso por cada
unidad adicional sea más alto que su
costo por unidad querrá producir más y
más hasta el punto en el que su costo
marginal sea igual a su ingreso marginal
y así la cantidad racional a producir
sería justo aquí
le voy a poner q podría llamar a esto q
para la empresa también podría llamarle
q sub m de mercado porque estamos
lidiando con una situación en la que la
empresa al menos del lado del productor
es el mercado es el único productor es
un monopolio pero cuál es el precio aquí
bueno para saberlo solo tenemos que ver
la curva de demanda en esta cantidad el
precio está justo aquí entonces el
precio está justo aquí y una vez más
podríamos llamar a esto el precio de
mercado y entonces aquí ha ocurrido algo
interesante para la empresa monopólica
en una empresa perfectamente competitiva
el punto donde se intersectan las curvas
de demanda y costo marginal es lo que
dictaba la demanda porque la curva de
demanda y la curva de ingreso marginal
eran las mismas pero aquí estamos
produciendo una cantidad menor que eso
estamos produciendo una cantidad donde
el precio es mayor que el costo marginal
puedes verlo aquí con esta cantidad el
precio es mayor que el costo marginal
por lo que puedes ver esta diferencia
que tenemos
y como un tipo de margen de ganancia que
una empresa monopólica puede tener y que
no sería posible con una empresa
perfectamente competitiva y esto también
introduce una idea de pérdida de
eficiencia debido a que al menos en
teoría en una cantidad mayor las
personas estaban dispuestas a pagar más
que el costo marginal por lo que
pensarías que hay algún tipo de ganancia
que el mercado en conjunto podría
obtener de esas unidades adicionales y
luego incluso algunas unidades
adicionales más se puede sentir que
pueden existir ganancias pero debido a
la producción racional para esta empresa
monopólica ya que existen barreras
insuperables para que otras empresas
ingresen al mercado esto no se va a
obtener por lo que existe esta pérdida
de eficiencia ahora una pregunta
interesante y aquí es donde comencé cuál
sería la ganancia económica para esta
empresa monopólica y para pensar en eso
tenemos que pensar en su curva de costo
total promedio
y así el costo total promedio dibujaré
una curva de costo total promedio típica
podría verse como algo así si bien el
costo marginal está por debajo del costo
total promedio el costo total promedio
tendrá una tendencia descendente y tan
pronto como el costo marginal sea más
alto que el costo total promedio bueno
ahora el costo total promedio comenzará
a ascender así que los costos marginales
intersectan la curva de costo total
promedio en el punto mínimo justo allí y
así con base en esta curva de costo
total promedio parece que esta empresa
monopólica está obteniendo una ganancia
económica porque a esta cantidad este es
el precio por unidad que está obteniendo
este es el costo total promedio por
unidad así que en promedio por unidad
está alcanzando esta altura está
obteniendo esta diferencia aquí y luego
si tuvieras que multiplicarla por la
cantidad de unidades eso te dará su
ganancia económica de modo que podrías
ver la ganancia económica en esta
situación como el área sombreada de este
rectángulo lo dejaré aquí lo importante
que hay que apreciar es que cuando nos
enfrentamos a la competencia en perfecta
y a la forma extrema de un monopolio su
curva de ingreso marginal ya no es su
curva de demanda y su curva de ingreso
marginal tiene una pendiente descendente
como ésta ya no es la plana no es como
la curva que vimos con la competencia
perfecta y debido a eso su costo
marginal intersec a el ingreso marginal
en una cantidad donde el precio es mayor
que el costo marginal lo que introduce
una pérdida de eficiencia en el mercado
y la manera de pensar sobre la ganancia
económica es comparar cuál es ese precio
del mercado en esa cantidad con costo
total promedio en esa cantidad y lo que
también es interesante sobre esta
empresa monopólica es que debido a las
barreras de entrada de las que hablamos
a largo plazo con competencia perfecta
si hay ganancias económicas entrarán más
participantes al mercado pero eso no va
a suceder en un monopolio porque las
barreras de entrada son muy altas
entonces este monopolio se ve bastante
bien va a poder seguir con este tipo de
ganancia económica a menos que de alguna
manera algo cambió dramáticamente en el
mercado